tonight our series on the state of the
metropolitan police department continues
while there have been calls for police
reform one major change that took place
at metro involves the banning
of a controversial restraint by officers
called a lateral
vascular neck restraint the department
took action in july
to limit its use and then during a
special session nevada legislators
banned it
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
broader look at a number of use of force
incidents at the hands of metro officers
the department of justice announced in
2012 the metro police department needed
to change
after an extensive review the doj wrote
in this report
the shooting of unarmed suspects remains
a concern
for example between 2007 and 2011 there
were 10
officer involved shootings that involved
unarmed suspects
seven were black i think it's safe to
say they were not in keeping
with best practices the department
implemented multiple changes
in 2019 metro reports out of 16
shootings by police
15 of the subjects were armed there is
an
emphasis on de-escalation techniques
in this report analyzing a five-year
period through 2019
the department provides use of force
data while also acknowledging
lessons are still being learned it notes
four critical incidents in 2019
in which the coroner determined officers
actions
may have contributed to the subject's
cause of death
[Music]
the clark county coroner's office ruled
byron williams death a homicide because
the prone restraint officers placed him
in was a factor
in addition to meth in his system and
health issues
he ran from police after they tried
stopping him for not having a bicycle
light
once they had him in custody williams
told officers he couldn't breathe at
least 24
times multiple officers deactivated
their body cameras
at the scene he deserves justice like
what they did to him
was not was not right it was not fair it
was inhumane
the use of force review board comprised
of both commissioned officers and three
citizens
determined officers should have
immediately rolled williams on his side
after he was handcuffed
and their medical response violated
training and policy
metro took action notifying all officers
to place suspects on their side or sit
them up
so they are not kept in a position like
williams was
and to get medical attention immediately
in a situation like this
the department also updated policy
officers must keep their body cameras on
while at a scene
donovan britt is a citizen volunteer on
the review board we kind of see
these events and we understand what they
should be doing and something that's
outside of the norm we have
we can focus in on and go why is that
the case the board also makes
recommendations on officer discipline
according to the department out of 31
cases reviewed in 2019
14 officers were disciplined none were
fired
and one resigned captain fred haas works
in internal affairs
if there are bad cops out there i don't
want them standing next to me out there
in the community
and throughout the community in 2020
there were black lives matter protests
and calls for police reform while metro
is more advanced than many departments
incidents like william's death
demonstrate there are still
serious flaws that need to be fixed
vanessa murphy 8 news now we also have
more information on police use of force
hirings and firings and diversity on the
force on 8newsnow.com
click on the state of metro banner
you'll find that right at the top of the
page